are there scenes where there's some
fights where it becomes very emotion oh
yeah berry and how is that for you when
they cut and you've had to raise your
voice or get mad do you need a moment
now would you want to keep going I don't
need anything I can go I can cry
I can laugh I can get angry I am like
ass if it just goes in and out of me and
it's all fun
I like feelings I like to have a lot of
feelings I love to cry I'd love to get
angry I love to be scared
I love to do all the feelings joy I'm
trying to think if there's any feeling
that I don't like playing the hardest
feeling to play is no feeling to be
repressed to be dull to be boring is the
hardest thing to play is that because
you feel emotions so right now because
there's a lot of feeling that goes into
no feeling there's a lot of feeling that
goes into repression a lot of feelings
so if you've had to play that character
before it doesn't sound like with this
mother character that that's what you're
playing but how do you go there then how
do you become so banal or flat well you
have all the feelings but you don't show
them you don't express them they're all
there and you rise above them or you
don't show them actually it's a very
interesting thing to play
you